so I decided to take a look at one of my
favorite websites Netflix I'm gonna open
up dev tools by pressing command option
I turn on emulation and go into the
timeline I will do a hard reload by
doing command shift R and we can see the
events that happen as the page is
loading let's take a look at the first
couple we can see we send a request for
the home page here this is the HTML file
that we need to load the page let's
scroll down we can see that when the
HTML file finishes loading we then parse
the HTML let's open this up and we see a
request for two different files both
called include clicking on the first one
gives us this CSS file scrolling down I
think we can pick out two pretty obvious
optimizations just looking at this file
the first optimization is to minify the
CSS or get rid of all the white space
the white space in the file only helps
us read it it doesn't help the browser
parse the file so in fact if we got rid
of all the white space we would remove a
significant amount of bytes from our
data the second optimization is to
inline critical CSS and we wouldn't have
to send out another request for this CSS
file to style this page